can you just give me a quick most likely
too you'd be in a boxing match oh JJ
Okay so you'd be him yeah okay
just so get some headlines
yes my peoples is trying to say today
lab Bible are going to quiz me on my
social media so there's a picture on my
Instagram this is the beta squad on the
sidemen so the caption is beta Squad X
sidemen
a blank who is missing from this picture
and what were they doing Kenny and Kenny
I think he was in the toilet I think
you're gonna start having a poo yes
I generally remember this because we
were all gathered and they needed to
leave Kenny was just pooing and I was
like oh where where is he and it's
almost like he's having I was like what
we're gonna do then we need to take the
picture so we take a picture and
everyone felt like we like took him out
the picture my purpose or he took the
picture I know he was just in the toilet
so he missed his uh big big moment which
is taking a picture of the sidemen which
was incredible for us at the time they
did a hide and seek in our house for
their channel so it was weird it was
crazy one and I remember winning money
off JJ KSI because I snitched and told
him where someone was
and I literally gave me the money there
and then look at that five hours ago I
thought yeah yeah he's too rich can you
just give me a quick most likely too so
most likely to end up in jail probably
Harry that's crazy it'd get loan you
some cash JJ KSI every day of the week
you'd be in a boxing match oh JJ okay so
you'd beat him that'd be him okay
just so I get some headlines
oh yeah big day big day do you want to
play the video I'll play the video
[Music]
I already know this I did
yeah he's crazy I know about it this is
this is recent
[Music]
ly
we've been following each other on
searches for a long time the link has
always been like stopped once by covid
once because he was in London and when I
was in Toronto and finally it happened
and like he's always been like showing
me love on social media so it was it was
nice to get it in person it was exactly
the same if not even better in real life
so I didn't want to film this video
because I don't want like a fanboy I
don't want to be like waited up but he
kept filming me on his phone so I was
like yeah flip this let me just get a
drink on my videos I started recording
and then he came straight towards me
just grabbing by the shoulders and
showed me the Same Love Like I said so
yeah it's my favorite artist from 2012
so it's crazy yeah yeah wild they took
me to dinner I was at his house
um went to a club with together like
we've done some career some great it's
great stuff mad moments yeah you know
I've got his number as well don't have
to brag though you don't ask me that me
so this is uh at running no lead
Festival yeah unless you came out for
stormzy on lease Festival uh
other people but it was me and Jack
grillish yeah and we came out on stage
as this surprise guest and I felt bad
because I wasn't going to do anything to
surprise them you know usually you get
like a Dave to come out yeah yeah yeah
there's a chance I was like what's up
guys I'm not gonna sing anything but hi
that's just Grillo that's great like
Grillo yeah gorilla is that his nickname
yeah you know you got nicknames for your
friends describe to me your first
Instagram [ __ ]
goodness gracious no clue
do you remember Man of the Year
almost 10 years ago huh yeah it was 2013
wasn't it it's wild man genuinely this
is crazy I remember I thought I looked
absolutely impeccable I thought no one
could talk to me if I'm being honest I
remember going to that prom that day and
no one had a fitted suit everyone was a
bit baggy yeah whereas my dad's a suit
salesman so he made so I look good yeah
that's my little secret I just gave it
to you guys I want best dress in the 11
prom and the Affinity prompt shout out
to Dad you know I mean it made sure I
look good okay next one this is probably
a good memory for you as well great
memory great memory this is when I broke
into the football scene I know chunks is
a celebration you wanted me
do you remember which team Mason played
against when he first did that
celebration of the Frankenstein that's
what I got asked potentially uh he got
killed on Twitter because we were like
what the hell is Robbie celebration and
I was like it's me it's my celebration
but yeah after that time to do it I
watched I watched the next two Chelsea
games yeah and then I didn't because I
was asleep one day and my phone was a
butt back going crazy because I think
this was a Saturday 12 p.m kickoff yeah
and I wasn't I was asleep and then
everyone was called a message saying oh
Mason did it Mason did it I said what'd
you talk about so now I watched on
Twitter and I saw him do that and I was
just I was literally shocked because I
didn't believe he was going to remember
yeah yeah so I just kept rewinding and I
was like yo that's actually myself Mason
keeps asking for a new one so I need to
give him a new one how is it yeah he's
tired he's tired of the Frankenstein so
they keep they keep taking a piss out of
him and training and stuff saying you
keep doing the same celebration so that
kind of stuff must be mad for you though
to like wild I get footballers from the
whole Premier League was asking me give
me a celebration give me a celebration
because I was waiting for one Trent
Alexander Arnold's waiting for one but I
need it to be original sir
okay oh yeah thank you back to the skin
okay so caption is Mr pen by blank so
who really won I don't know Mario yeah
that was my I was so disheartened like I
was like wow how did I miss why did I
miss I was at the school you know I mean
and then when John Terry's walked up and
said I'm missing the Champions League
final I was like okay well yeah I get it
it's not it's not that bad then yeah
yeah I understand so I said lost blank
in crypto today alone send help I said
oil record labels I might be making a
cut back
do you remember how much uh no I don't
there's a lot of money though bloody
hell you think it was more or less than
JJ way less oh my God I want to FaceTime
just to laugh at him because I'm
actually lost like I'm not speaking to
buy him he was giving me little tips and
that and obviously he made a lot of
money but at one point where I think it
was Luna that just killed him yeah yeah
and he made I think Millions like lost
millions are sorry about that no I
thought Yeah well yeah I felt like crap
that day there was a 270k or something
yeah almost exactly 3K 274.
[Music]
so how old were you here 10 years less
than I am now in 2016. wow okay yeah
whose medal are you wearing is that
Anthony Joshua's
[Music]
my dad's a big fan of boxing yeah so
we're watching the Olympics that year I
think it was like yeah very closely
and then um tell me about this guy like
won the boxing called Anthony Joshua and
were watching it and I was like yeah I
really like this guy so I was walking
past Sudbury
and funny enough the Barber's called
Olympic Barbers which is hilarious I was
walking past and then one of my friends
like yo yo look he's gonna turn that
gold medalist guy at least that's what
he called him and I was like oh yeah it
is walked in
um I was like a picture of you and he's
like one second I got something even
better and I was like what and he goes
he went in this car it was like a it was
like a course or I think it was just
like a rubbish cast I remember and he
went to this guy took out the medal and
I was like oh snap and then he goes yeah
take a picture you can take you can hold
you can put the metal on I was like why
is this guy so nice to me you know what
I mean so I I thanked him so much for
that took a picture and then the second
time I met him again was when we did a
lynx commercial when I was an ambassador
he was an ambassador and straight away
like we'll speak about that moment for
about an hour you remember do you
remember
all right open your mouth
so what did he think was in his mouth
a horse [ __ ] was it he's just a crazy
doctor he did oh he must have said
something loud I know I'm not crazy
right now okay I'm definitely a [ __ ] or
something along the lines of that okay
otherwise I look crazy
I swear I thought it was a genuine penis
the last part I did yeah
which very famous person did you say
that you look like yeah
I was a big fan of EastEnders my Victor
was actually standards I love you stand
as well it's been wrong for about six
years bloody yeah I've done a lot I
don't know
yeah good times thank you
Good Times
[Music]
oh bro what that smells like [ __ ] ass
my in Ash juice what is this